so drill three again you're going to go
to Y on the back foot and then y on the
front foot okay so it's it's uh you have
to do the full motion okay so you go
here and then the
projection take his ground and then move
forward try to relax as you feel both
his pressure and as you increase it as
you go forward stay
relaxed okay so your knees do have to go
that far on exercise three okay a detail
so when he comes in with his linear uh
Force right it has a rate he decides the
rate okay uh that he's going to put into
the equation but I decide at at what
rate it moves me onto the back foot okay
so for example I'm I'm in on me I I can
still ground from here you can't push me
over okay and so I decide at what rate
we go onto the back foot okay uh and
that is important because in this drill
I'm not doing any absorption with my
hands okay so the absorption is all my
is on my uh weight
shifting so if I go if I go at One Rate
you're going to see that ah man it was
he was too fast for the rate that I
allowed to get my weight onto that back
foot and it goes into your shoulders
okay I contact your grounding your
grounding ball and you decide the rate
and so I decide the rate as I go forward
here okay so I don't want my hands to
move uh in and out on exercise three I
decide the rate that we go back and boom
I decide the rate that we go
forward I decide the rate forward
okay try it again in uh in your art
we're going to displace your base right
so we're going to use that
triangular angle of
Kam get it this this is uh using these
internal development drills but putting
it in
okay Kam is not necessary to project you
okay and so uh drill four will show that
but I would like to show you how in uh
drill three it's it's the same thing
okay so I want you to pay attention to
when he actually
leaves me okay if you pay
attention it's not when I get there
that's not when he Le leav okay
boom I not there yet do you see that
okay and this goes
to the fact that my back
foot uh should never unground so I
shouldn't ever go boom and boom and I'm
pushing with my back foot okay the back
foot stays heavy throughout the movement
okay drill four if you were pushing with
your if you were pushing off of your
back foot and trying to adopt a bracing
angle to Lunge him off of you he hadn't
left yet um one when you go to your art
you're always going to enter in a young
young class see I I've enter but he's
not there anymore he's already going
that way do you understand so drill four
is to emphasize that and in drill four
my front knee does not leave the yin
face so it doesn't go past ankle
straight okay so as we go in
h so the same thing applies you see how
I take him at the rate that I want onto
the back foot I still have to do that
but I just go to knee
straight that's all I do here
okay
okay try it okay so what what I meant
like drill three drill three is going to
give you your your uh triangular sound
you see that we use do you get it so
what where I threw and how I threw is
the same internal components it's still
a Coq projection okay but now uh we have
a drill four okay why do we need drill
four just like you needed drill three
okay why didn't we just stick with
standing
meditation uh because we need checks and
balances you see so each drill is not
necessarily a harder skill it's just
less capable of being duplicated by
external Force engines okay that's what
that's what it's doing so you may find
at this point damn I can't I can't do
this well the same way if you found if
if you thought you were doing standing
meditation but you could not ground
Vector in drill two then you weren't
doing standing meditation okay so
likewise if you thought you were
projecting and that guy moved backwards
if you find in drill three the guy moved
backwards cuz you're projecting and you
didn't realize you're just pushing him
into this bracing angle instead of
realizing he's already gone he has to be
gone for me to enter
he leaves about this part okay drill
four is going that's all you get is that
part let's see if he left or not okay
making it harder all right got it so as
I as I'm doing this uh everything should
be the same if it's not the same then
it's cuz I'm not doing it I didn't do it
that's what happened that's how these
drills work okay so again it doesn't
matter um we had a question question
over here is like when I straighten my
leg I feel like I'm on my heel and he
can push me over again the shape of the
front leg does not matter that's why I
take the take it off a lot to show you
that if the leg the leg can do anything
it doesn't matter I'm still grounding
okay you get
it
so but our drill has a rule so I'm in k
a i would be in k a but I don't go to k
a i just go to there that's all I'm
doing in Dr four on pull
off and I release and relax on off okay
try it
again okay I kind of gave it away in the
in my last demo where I said the leg's
not important okay uh for a lot of
people to start uh I and I even I to
start the leg's important okay but if
you think that it has a particular
shape uh your I'm sorry your Li your
understanding is very limited okay it
does not have a shape it's it's about
formlessness so it doesn't matter how I
stand it doesn't doesn't even matter
that I'm on that midfoot that is not
that's just to get me in the ballpark
okay it's not relevant it's may be
relevant for Marshall concerns but in
terms of what we're doing with this
internal Force engine is not relevant
okay so if you look at these drills as
are get get harder and as I said we're
making them
less um duplicatable by external Force
engines what we're doing is we're taking
advantage of the fact that I don't need
an anatomical structure to do these kind
of things okay um so on this next one uh
drill five I'm actually going to go in
go into him okay so he's walking at me
and I walking to
him
but I'm not going to bra there's not a
class where it goes into my shoulders or
anything uh and so I won't have
necessarily perfect midfoot whatever is
touching I let that bounce off of there
and I project okay so we're walking at
each other
and
okay let's try it all right drill
five is doesn't change anything so my
hands aren't going to go here and and
then project out okay I leave I leave my
hands where they are you might see this
kind of like he he pulsed on it but once
they pulse then I don't keep projecting
out okay um the wave that you're seeing
isn't so much in me it's that his energy
is going to the ground and then comes
back just depends on what you're looking
at so I think most people that see this
they realize he it looks like he came in
and then he bounced back and then the
EGP part mind goes and he went in and
then he went out okay but I think if you
just focus on my hands either plot them
in space or my elbows or something like
that and you see that's not actually
what happens although he looks like he's
rebounding okay so we're walking at each
other my hands are
loose hands are just
[Applause]
loose not not going like this
that's that's something else okay I'm
not doing that just
absorb in and through me okay so the the
rebounding that you're seeing is
important because that's the energy
that's going through me but it's not
that I do it externally with my arms
okay not in this drill
try Okay drill six I take away the
bracing angle okay so he's pushing and
we could do drill six is where I'm just
here if he lets go I don't go flying no
I should just stay where I'm at he lets
go
boom or drill seven you can
project so I'm not going backwards okay
there's it's hard to do the weight
shifting so I will allow that you're
going to use your arms here ground or
and you won't fly backwards if you're
grounding properly you won't fly
backwards
just like you wouldn't fall forward okay
if you're not grounding properly when
you push him You' be pushing yourself
over okay so drill six you could do it
static drill seven project and stay
static okay and I'm allowing some arm
movement
in but as I do my arms they're very
relaxed when again if you pay attention
he's gone there you see my arms don't
need to go there they go there because
our art continues the IES we're it
either sticks or it follows okay so you
should train for stick and following but
he should be gone on this part
boom okay let's
try Okay uh the same drills can be done
with a weapon on a
person and then also a weapon against a
weapon okay so we're not going to go
into those things um but just just to
understand especially ski ski is very
important so he holds on to the tip okay
and um I don't want him to push me over
okay and I do my
ski you can do it walking at
him you got to grab it well whatever you
touch you can't project okay whatever
you touch is you can't
project you can do it in your
horse do don't matter okay uh and
then as you make your way towards
iky you can do this where I counter
it
okay so if I'm doing drill one I'm here
then
move okay actually I use drill three
okay so all I did was as as his grip I
came around this way and I have to match
his Yang energy otherwise I'll go flying
past him and he'll go flying on me it's
not that I it's not that I grab him back
okay so it's a it's a higher set drills
if I'm doing drill three boom and stuck
and then
project drill
four drill five into
him whenever you touch you touch it
doesn't
matter five okay
um on the more stance
okay um that maybe Beyond us I think
we're we're here we're losing everyone
and probably losing you at the beginning
but if you pull out what I've done with
the drills believe me you don't need
these drills okay it's in the
kihon
um the only reason I have drills is to
stop the ego tripartite mind from
fabricating the delusion and then wiping
all traces away that it fabricated the
delusion so the teacher is the kind of
light of Truth truth and we get to see
well can you or can't you not okay and
so all these drills are not designed but
for being tasked with how do I get the
student to realize they're not doing it
you make it impossible to do another way
okay hence these drills all right so
we're going to keep working on these
here we go